the military investigates cadets for
flashing an okay symbol on national
television a Democrat switches parties
over impeachment and president Trump
goes after Nancy Pelosi's teeth I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show in
just a minute we're gonna get to all of
the impeachment related stuff today's
show is sponsored by expressvpn it's how
my listeners secure their Internet join
them at expressvpn calm /ban so over the
weekend I was reading this great book by
a MIDI slaves called great society all
about the growth of government under
Lyndon Baines Johnson and one of the
fascinating aspects of this particular
book is the manipulation of the currency
the incredible amounts of manipulation
of the currency that went on under LBJ
had also gone on under FDR basically
whenever the government wants to spend
doodles of money and doesn't actually
want to pay for it they just inflate the
currency and they screw around with the
exchange rate on gold they'll take gold
out of the market LBJ actually set it up
said you could only exchange gold at the
at the window the so-called federal
window if you were a foreign country but
at the same time on the private market
gold was more expensive than if you were
a foreign country trying to exchange for
gold in the American markets bottom line
is this when governments want to screw
around with the currency they will screw
around with the currency well how do you
insure yourself against that you invest
a little bit in precious metals you
diversify into precious metals this is
why I've recommended to lots of folks
that they check out Birch gold now is
the time to get in touch with the folks
over at Birch gold the folks I trust
they're putting out an offer I've never
seen them put out and I've been working
with them for years it is the silver
stocking stuffer event when you contact
purchased gold group this month to buy
precious metals once you complete your
purchase before December 20th Birch gold
will send you free silver they have a
great stocking stuffer or Hanukkah gift
have a conversation with the Birch gold
expert see if precious metals make sense
for your family I trust them they're the
people that I know and they are the
people that you should trust once you've
asked all your questions and become
comfortable with the idea of
diversifying into precious metals just
text Ben to 47 47 47 claim your
eligibility for this special offer today
again text been in - 47 47 47 text Ben's
47 47 47 opened that account with Birch
gold group get free 100 percent silver
go check them out right now text Ben -
47 47 47 okay so we'll get to everything
impeachment related this week is a big
week for the Democrats the impeachment
will go through this week the Democrats
will Ram this thing through they've sent
for an almost 700 page report to the
rest of Congress
the president Trump is guilty of bribery
even though they're naturally charging
him with bribe we're gonna get to all of
that in just a moment but frankly it's a
foregone conclusion I don't think
anything has changed it feels like a
put-up job most independents in the
country are not fond of this there was a
late-breaking poll over the weekend
showing that while 85 percent of
Democrats support impeachment first of
all it's a low number right you'd expect
it to be like 98 percent of Democrats
support impeachment it's only about 85
percent only 7% of Republicans support
impeachment and then in the middle the
independents only 43% support
impeachment so this thing is not
breaking in favor of the Democrats so
that means that for me frankly this is a
sort of secondary issue I know it's
weird to say the impeachment of the
president in the House of
Representatives for the third time in
American history would actually
represent a nothing burger but in fact
it sort of does because the fact is that
the Senate is not going anywhere with
all of this so believe it or not the
bigger story over the weekend is the
continuing degradation of our culture
the continuing stupidity of the media
I'm speaking of course of the attempt to
the attempt to Covington Catholic
members of the military cadets at the
Army Navy game so according to The
Huffington Post military officials have
launched an investigation after the OK
hand symbol that has become known as a
symbol for white power was flashed I'm
in a crowd of cadets before the Army
Navy game in Philadelphia on Saturday so
there is the Army Navy game president
Trump shows up to this every year and a
bunch of the cadets are giving the okay
symbol now you may you may be saying
yourself what the hell how is this in
any way racist how many times have you
said your friend okay right how many
times have you done there's actually an
OK emoji on on text on Twitter is that
because it's white power
so here's what happened 4chan which is
this message board many of the message
boards on 4chan are not racist or white
supremacist some of them absolutely are
and idiots on 4chan decided that what
would be a great prank to play on the
media because the media are gullible is
to suggest that every time somebody
flashed a okay symbol what they were
actually doing was flashing a white
power symbol how would this work well
because if you hold up your hands in an
okay then you get a w and a P uh-huh
it's like white power you get so clever
is have it now everybody has flashed the
okay symbol at some point in fact in the
NBA many NBA players who are black
are flashing the okay not because
they're actually saying okay but because
they give a three-pointer right yeah
there's lots of graphics of Steph Curry
doing the three points or sign after he
hits a three-pointer okay one of the
other aspects of okay is that people
have been using the okay symbol for
decades to play something known as the
circle game the circle game is where you
hold up the okay symbol below your waist
and if somebody looks at it you punch
them in the shoulder it's the dumbest
game ever okay but people have been
doing this I remember people did this
even in my middle school this is like an
actual thing so cadets epi at the
army/navy game we're doing this it's
pretty obvious that that's what they're
doing but they're not giving the white
power symbol at the army/navy game now
that's not what's happening here because
three separate cadets do it do you think
they're all these white supremacist who
just happen to be in camera view or are
they playing this back and forth circle
game or if you see the okay symbol then
get punched in the shoulder and
everybody I know who's in the military
knows exactly what this is I have
friends who have served in those heard
David French who served in the military
served in Iraq he immediately was like
guys what are you crazy and david has no
interest none of us have any interest in
protecting white supremacists in their
stupid hijacking of a hand symbol none
of us have any interest in that haven't
personally targeted by white
supremacists David's been targeted more
than I have he has an adopted black
daughter like this is all insanity so
here is the tape you can see that behind
this particular sportscaster who's at
Rees Davis you can see there's a kid who
puts his hands out he's wearing a glove
and he puts out his hand in the circle
game and then another kid puts out his
hand in the circle game so is it just
that Reese Davis happens to be in the
center of the KKK when the KKK
contingent of the of West Point this is
where he was or is it that everybody is
just playing the circle game the media
decide that it's that everybody
including apparently the kid who's
obviously of color standing next to rece
Davis and has no problem I assume he's
not like fightin fist fighting the kids
who are right behind him that all of
these kids who are who are flashing the
circle game that is why first of all it
doesn't make any sense okay if you're
gonna do the okay symbol as a
quote-unquote white power symbol you
can't hold it down okay then it's not a
W anymore this whole thing is idiotic
the military isn't how investigating
this the military is doing a full-scale
investigation into this a full-scale
investigation
because everyone has lost their mind his
everyone is stupid and everyone has to
take offense at everything and if you
don't take offense it's because you're
insensitive to the needs of people
alternatively these kids are playing the
circle game and that's it so Huffington
Post reports military this was their
headline yesterday big flashing headline
military investigating after cadets
flash apparent white power signs before
Army Navy game this is not a white power
sign guys it's not their pictures of
Barack Obama doing their pictures of NBA
players doing it there's pictures of
everybody doing it are you insane
how have you bought into this the
anti-defamation league even put out a
statement about a year and a half ago
about the so called white power signs
saying this is not an actual white power
sign this is just there's just trolls
over at 4chan trying to make it appear
that white supremacists are hiding under
your bed even the ADL was smart enough
to recognize this but not our media meri
pappenphus writing for The Huffington
Post
she says military officials have
launched an investigation hey this is
not Abu Ghraib this is kids playing the
circle game you idiots military
officials have launched an investigation
after the OK hand symbol that has become
known as a symbol for white power how's
it become known as that like if you
weren't on Twitter let's say you didn't
spend your entire life being an idiot on
Twitter and you spent your entire life I
don't know going to sports games or
engaging with your children or going to
go into the mall like having a job being
a useful human being would there be how
many people in the United States would
be sitting around going oh my god I just
saw this kid go like that
for sure that kid is in his off hours he
goes over to Bed Bath & Beyond picks up
a sheet and flounces around West Point
the gestures were captured on national
TV during a pregame broadcast in a crowd
that included black cadets well these
are the black cadets were very upset by
it they appeared to be flashed by both
West Point cadets and Annapolis
Midshipmen oh it's an interior military
KKK branch it's just like the new HBO
series Watchmen they've taken over all
of the auspices of law enforcement we're
looking into a West Point representative
Lieutenant Colonel Chris Hart told the
Wall Street Journal we don't know what
their intention is Annapolis spokeswoman
commander Elana Garris told Lee a
newspaper we are aware and will be
looking into it the signs were flashed
during a spot by ESPN's rece Davis
before the game at one point one of the
cadets in the stands around Davis stood
laughing and showed a banner reading go
army beat Navy and someone behind him
whose face was out of the shot and
wearing a black
glove Oh a black glove you mean cuz it's
cold outside wearing a black glove made
the hand sign at least two other signs
were also flashed one next to Davis's
head ah
obviously the gropers have taken over
West Point the story quickly blew up on
social media cuz social media is a place
for idiots the anti-defamation league
this year added the symbol to its list
of hate signs yes but that's only after
they recognized it was not actually a
hate sign and the whole thing was being
promoted by all of these groups in order
to make it appear as though there were
vast scores of people all across the
country who routinely engaged in secret
white supremacist hands symbols the
symbol began as a trolling hoax by
members of the website 4chan saying the
hand gesture formed a WNEP for white
power but the gesture is now being used
in some circles as a sincere expression
of white supremacy according to the ADL
I mean they tried this with Steven
Miller very on in the administration
when he gave an OK symbol to the camera
it was like aha well that's because he
says he's signaling to his white
supremacist friends guys and we had a
story like this not that long ago it was
last year actually the US Coast Guard
said it had removed a member from its
Hurricane Florence response team on
Friday after he made an okay hand
gesture on live TV that the service
branch deemed offensive the unidentified
team member was caught looking into the
camera and then swiftly making the hand
gesture prompting a backlash on social
media the hand signal was seen in the
background of MSNBC's live interview
with section Charleston commanding
officer Captain John Reed this is last
year who's providing an update on
actions taken by the Coast Guard many
social media users called for the firing
of the individual throw a guy out of the
Coast Guard because he made a so called
white power hate symbol alternatively he
was playing in the circle game on
national TV and this has become a thing
it's not actually a bunch of secret
white supremacist hiding in plain sight
this is so unbelievably stupid it's so
dumb but it doesn't matter the media is
gonna play this thing up anyway this
became a national scandal in Malcolm
Nance on MSNBC he said this is now a
national it's a national scandal guys
because they've taken over they've taken
over everywhere people with their okay
hand symbols everywhere and also their
words in my Cheerios they all say ooh
here's a competitive easy there is a
very large hammer coming down from the
Commandant office and the commander's
office at the Naval Academy
because again this is now a national
scandal even though it might not be a
scandal but you know what we're gonna
find out and all of their senior
non-commissioned officer senior ranking
officers are going to be coming down on
top of them like a ton of bricks
because they have disgraced the Armed
Forces whether they were just as we say
lollygagging and playing around or
whether they actually had the intent to
make that symbol in front of a national
audience you've got to be kidding me
lollygagging isn't even the proper word
there in any case but what well done
Malcolm Nance
well done right on top of it the media's
attempts to Covington Catholic people is
just insane I know that's become a verb
now the reason it's become a verb is
because the media have an interest in
taking situations out of context and
then determining that these are secret
symbols of white supremacy so kids
wearing Magga hats standing there while
they're abused by black Hebrew
Israelites or and the Native American
guy who's getting all in their face and
they're just standing there those kids
are the real problem these kids who are
playing the circle game and serving in
the military which by the way nobody in
the media including me is doing hey
those kids are the problem according to
the media unbelievable okay in just a
second we're gonna get to the latest
stop to the social justice warrior to
left this of course happening on college
campuses but first let's talk about your
sleep experience so I am preparing for a
new baby that means I am stocking up on
as much sleep as I can get right now
because when that baby comes I'm never
going to sleep again well if I'm
stocking up on sleep that means there's
only one mattress I will lie upon and
that of course is my helix sleep
mattress personalized for me
Hewitt's sleep has a quiz it takes two
minutes to complete it matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you no matter how
you sleep on side back hot sleeper
whatever helix can make what your body
needs just go to helix sleep calm /ban
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life when I'm on the road I cannot
wait to get home and into that bed
because it is made for me I'm like the
hotel mattresses which are made for
everybody for couples Helix can even
split the mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they've
got a 10-year warranty you get to try it
out for a hundred nights risk-free it'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it so there is no risk involved but
you're gonna love it helix is offering
up to 125 bucks off all mattress orders
for our listeners get up to 125 bucks
off at helix sleep comm slash Ben that's
helix sleep comm / Ben from - 125
dollars off your mattress order helix
sleeeeep calm /ban go check them out
right now well speaking of the the sort
of surrender to social justice warrior
mindset college campuses are now seeking
apparently according to the Associated
Press to set up slavery reparations at
college campuses now last I checked
slavery was ended
Juneteenth happened in 1863 so it's been
approximately a hundred and fifty six
years since the official end of slavery
in the north it's been a long time since
slavery ended that is not to say that
there are no vestiges of slavery just
like there's vestiges of any piece of
history in American history there are
more vestiges of Jim Crow or that wealth
holdovers from generation to generation
these are things that occur but the idea
that you are going to pay slavery
reparations from a university to people
who are now what five generations
removed from slavery at least at least
maybe six or seven generations removed
depending on how fast people have kids
leave measurement of a generation if you
say it's 20 years for example then you
are talking about nearly ten generations
removed from well nearly fifteen JIT
about eight nine generations removed
from slavery
okay so The Associated Press says the
promise of reparations to atone for
historical ties to slavery has opened up
new territory in a reckoning at u.s.
colleges which until now have responded
with monuments building name changes in
public apologies Georgetown University
and two theological seminaries have
announced funding commitments to benefit
descendents of the enslaved people who
are sold or toiled to benefit the
institution's again you're now talking
about the great great great great great
great great grandchildren of all of the
people who served to build these
institutions when they were first built
you talking about paying them some sum
of money which is both insulting on the
one level because you can't pay people
off for the awful experiences that
they've had and also sort of ridiculous
because again when you're that many
generations removed you have many
ancestors I mean you have at that point
what 2020 and you have a bunch of
various great-great-great grandparents
right because it everybody has to for
every parent you've had there are two
grandparents so that means for every two
grandparents you've had there are four
grandparents so how exactly are you
going to figure out who deserves these
reparations how about people from a
mixed-race background how about people
who have 19
20 grandparents who great-great-great
great-great-great grandparents who are
not who are not insulated how exactly
are you gonna measure all of us none of
this matters it's all social justice
warrior signaling well no other schools
have gone so far the advantages that
institutions received from slavery from
the slavery economy are receiving new
attention as Democratic presidential
candidates talk about tax credits and
other subsidies that nudge the idea of
reparations toward the mainstream
University of Buffalo senior Jeffery
Clinton says he thinks campuses should
acknowledge historical ties to slavery
but the federal government should take
the lead on an issue that reaches well
beyond higher education he's a
descendant of slaves is this Jeffrey
Clinton Kennedy says it doesn't have to
be trillions of dollars but at least
address the inequities and attack the
racial wealth gap between
african-americans and white Americans
and really everybody else because this
is an American made institution we
didn't immigrate here that's true you
did not have a great here it is also
true and we are now 153 years removed
from the from the end of the Civil War
so at some point here we are going to
have to recognize that the best thing
that we can do is guarantee equal rights
not start signing people checks but
these universities obviously are in
thrall to the same - the same sjw
mindset that says that if you sign a
cheque that suddenly this is going to
fix everything which of course it is not
it is not come reckoning with American
history does not mean idiotic programs
that actually do not rectify the wrongs
that they seek to rectify it turns out
it's very difficult to have a time
machine where you can go back in time
and rectify this stuff by the way if you
want to talk about actual reparations
how about the victims of Jim Crow
instead of talking about slavery
reparations you actually should be
talking about Jim Crow reparations they
should have institutions that benefited
from Jim Crow if there were you know and
when I say if there were any there's
certainly institutions that benefited
from Jim Crow what I mean is that Jim
Crow in and of itself was not
economically beneficial is economically
backward which is why after the end of
Jim Crow but you saw his economic jumps
in in exactly the areas that ended Jim
Crow but these policies are not designed
to actually help people they are
designed to virtue signal they're not
designed to unite the country there's
not designed to divide the country
because they're impractical and
impracticable in just a second we're
gonna get you everything impeachment
related speaking of impractical
impractical and divisive we'll get to
all that in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that the First
Amendment is under assault in the United
States there's a whole group of people
on the Left who are interested in
curbing the First Amendment
because they don't want hate speech
promulgate now they want to find hate
speech they won't tell you what hate
speech constitutes but they would like
to rewrite the First Amendment to make
everybody feel better well this is why
the founders instituted the Second
Amendment because they understood that
assaults on fundamental rights are only
prevented by an armed population this is
something that the founders were very
much into it doesn't mean that we're on
the verge of a civil war god forbid it
does mean that the founders understood
that deterring the federal government
from overstepping its boundaries was a
key function of the Second Amendment
owning a rifle is an awesome
responsibility so is building rifles
starting to garage buy Marine veteran
more than two decades ago bravo company
manufacturing BCM for short builds a
professional-grade product built to
combat standards bravo company
manufacturing is not a sporting arms
company they design engineer and
manufacture life-saving equipment the
people at BCM assume that when rifle
leaves their shop it will be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen law enforcement officer or a
soldier overseas to learn more about the
awesome folks over at bravo company
manufacturing head on over to bravo
company MFG comm you can discover more
about their products special offers and
upcoming news that's Bravo Company em FG
comm if you need more convincing find
out even more about PCM and the awesome
people who make their products at
youtube.com slash bravo company USA
youtube.com / Bravo company USA they're
people that I would trust with my life
you should to check them out a Bravo
Company MFG comm Bravo Company MFG comm
alrighty so now on to impeachment gates
so this is supposed to be a very big
week as I said before I didn't lead off
the show with it because frankly I don't
think it's a very big week I think the
Democrats impeaching the president has
been a forgone conclusion since Nancy
Pelosi announced an impeachment inquiry
I don't think that anything
groundbreaking is going to happen here
and no matter how many white papers the
Democrats put out there they do not have
the goods the proof that they do not
have the goods is the fact that they did
not charge the president with bribery
there is no criminal charge anywhere in
the actual charges they charge from with
abuse of power which is not in fact a
crime it's a political crime and they
charged him with obstruction of Congress
which isn't only not a crime it isn't
even a thing that is wrong very often
that is called checks and balances
there's never been an obstruction of
Congress charged in an impeachment that
was not brought alongside an obstruction
of justice charge which would mean to
find the judicial branch and not justify
in Congress the executive defying
Congress is called checks and balances
it's a political reports
president from committed criminal
bribery and wire fraud the House
Judiciary Committee alleges and report
Oh accompany articles of impeachment
this week now you may notice those are
not actually charged in the impeachment
articles like those are actual crimes
wire fraud and bribery are actual crimes
you could be charged with bribery I
could be charged with wire fraud these
are actual criminal offenses
neither of them were included in the
articles of impeachment why the answer
is because the Democrats do not actually
have the supporting evidence that would
effectuate those charges they do not
that is why they charged something much
broader and they acknowledge this in the
report the report isn't 169 page
assessment of the case for Trump's
removal from office and it contends that
Trump committed multiple federal crimes
ones that Democrats addressed under the
broad umbrella of abuse of power the
first article of impeachment against the
president the panel's Democrats say
quote although president Trump's actions
need not rise to the level of a criminal
violation to justify impeachment his
conduct here was criminal they labeled
Trump's behavior both constitutional and
criminal and character and contended
that the people betrayed that the
president betrayed the people of this
nation and should be removed from office
which again begs a question why don't
you charge him with these things if you
are so confident of your ability to
charge and impeach a president convict
him in the Senate why not bring forth
actual charges why bring forth weak
charges like abuse of power and once
again the answer is you don't have the
goods and it really is not about the
charges it really is about getting from
patum office because Democrats keep
saying over and over that if Trump is
allowed to stand for reelection he might
win and if he wins they're not going to
respect the results of the elections
they are already setting up a
counter-narrative
which is that Trump stole election that
has not yet taken place which is pretty
incredible the staff report according to
Politico which was filed to the House
Rules Committee just after midnight on
Monday argues that President Trump
directed a months-long scheme to solicit
foreign interference in the twenty20
election the allegation that forms the
core of the two articles of impeachment
abuse of power and obstruction of
Congress approved by the Judiciary
Committee last week Democrats continued
to maintain over and over and over again
that they don't actually have to prove a
criminal violation which of course is
true they don't but it would help okay
the report says the framers were not
fools which by the way is the first time
that the Democrats have ever
acknowledged the framers were not fools
usually you get that the framers
they were operating in a different time
and different place the Second Amendment
is a load of bunk the first amendment
needs to be curbed campaign finance
reform hate speech laws and semuc rats
who are usually characterizing the
founders as rich white slave owners so
it's it's fun to hear them come around
to the idea of the framers were not
fools they say the framers were not
fools they authorized impeachment for a
reason and that reason would have been
gutted if impeachment were limited to
crimes well again it's not limited to
crimes but typically if you want some
sort of bipartisan support you would
want to prove a crime the Judiciary
Committee's report according to Politico
presents the panel's most thorough
analysis yet of why Democrats believe
the accusations against Trump are worthy
of immediate impeachment it comes a day
before the Rules Committee formally
considers the articles of impeachment
ahead of a likely Wednesday vote on the
House floor
it is obvious they're going to vote to
impeach him on Wednesday and all of the
rest of this is just window dressing
Democrats argue that Trump crossed the
threshold in to criminal behavior with
his posture toward ukrainian president
vladimir zolensky
writing in the report that his request
for the announcement of politically
motivated investigations constituted the
solicitation of a bribe under federal
law except for the fact that you have to
exchange anything of value and you have
to prove intent for bribery neither of
which the Democrats have actually proved
a thing of value typically is not
information and if you're going to say
that a thing of value is the
announcement of the investigation the
only testimony that suggests that he
only wanted the announcement and not the
investigation itself is that of Gordon
Sunland and even that is supposition by
Sunland the committee also alleges that
from violated the honest services wire
fraud statute during his July 25th phone
call which is a real stretch they can't
even show there was a quid pro quo on
the call right the call itself does not
demonstrate the quid pro quo so they're
saying that it's a wire fraud request
because he said in front of a bevy of
witnesses that the United States would
like a favor from the Ukrainians namely
investigate everything that went on in
2016 including hunter and Joe Biden in
the accompanying 18-page to sent you to
Sherry Committee Republicans led by
representative Doug Collins of Georgia
assailed Democrats evidences paltry and
in fronts to the constitutional process
of impeachment Palin said if President
Nixon's impeachment proceedings are the
gold standard for presidential
impeachment inquiries these proceedings
in stark contrast will go down in
history as the quintessential example of
how such proceedings should not be
conducted he blasted the articles of
impeachment as vague hyperbolic and
misleading particularly as they describe
fear
a future presidential misconduct and he
says guys if you keep saying criminality
then why aren't you alleging criminality
he says no president has been impeached
solely on non criminal allegations that
of course is absolutely true and again
the motivating factor here is to deal
with jibt amaizing the 2020 election to
say that if Trump is not impeached in
the here-and-now that he is going to
steal the election with the help of
foreign powers this again underscores
the Democrats claims that Hillary
Clinton in 2016 only lost because of the
interference of foreign powers not
because she was the world's most garbage
candidate which was false
she lost because she was indeed the
world's most garbage candidate you know
what have happened if WikiLeaks had
never hacked into the DNC emails you
know what have happened Hillary would
have lost really because the reason that
those emails even mattered is because
Hillary Clinton had hit 33,000 emails on
her private server that's what Trump
kept hammering home the WikiLeaks stuff
didn't really do much except keep things
in the news sort of
there was nothing extraordinarily
damning in the WikiLeaks cables and that
that were uncovered from the DNC really
it now I know there's a lot of dissent
on this I know there are a lot of people
in left saying no if it weren't for
WikiLeaks Hillary Clinton would be
president right now is such a narrow
election you can make the case it is my
contention that Hillary Clinton was such
a bad candidate that people's views of
her had been formed basically from the
beginning the national polling since the
beginning was pretty good and had her
winning the national polling was
accurate she did win nationally in the
popular vote in the swing states she
lost because people did not show up to
vote for her because she was a bad
candidate okay so what's the real
rationale behind this impeachment as I
say it really is not about what Trump
did it's really about Democrats fearing
he's going to win Senator Chris Coons of
Delaware he says he is gravely concerned
what Trump might do if not impeached
it's a pre-emptive impeachment it's like
pre-emptive war in Iraq it's pre-emptive
impeachment the only reason that speaker
Pelosi changed her position and
supported moving ahead with an
impeachment inquiry was because what
Donald Trump is alleged to have done and
all evidence points to him having done
it which is to invite foreign
interference in our next election
undermines the very core of our
democracy which is free and fair
elections where foreign parties aren't
influencing the outcome if he is
ultimately exonerated in the Senate if
the Senate Republican majority refuses
to discipline him through impeachment he
will be
bounded and I am gravely concerned about
what else he might do between now and
the 2020 election when there are no
restrictions on his behavior well I mean
there isn't there are restrictions on
his behavior the criminal law does not
cease to apply between you and pitching
him in the house and him being acquitted
in the Senate if it turns out that
tomorrow he goes over to the Ukrainians
and says to them in exchange for this
particular military aid I want you to
arrest Joe Biden with no charges
whatsoever you can impeach him again
tomorrow you can so that there are still
checks and balances it's just that you
guys have not proved your case you know
all of this LEDs the bizarre spectacle
over the weekend of the presidents of
the United States insulting Nancy Pelosi
Steve now let me just say I'm always up
for a good Nancy Pelosi teeth joke in
fact I'm the originator of many Nancy
Pelosi teeth jokes every time I do my
Nancy Pelosi impersonation it's
basically about her dentures flipping
around in that mouth Nancy Pelosi very
concerned how you weigh insulting me as
a Catholic I'm such a good Catholic
okay so Donald Trump the difference is
that trumps the president I'm just a guy
who's doing a podcast in any case he
says because Nancy so mark Meadows had
had tweeted out about a Nancy Pelosi
statement that it wasn't true and then
Trump said because Nancy's teeth were
falling out of her mouth and she didn't
have time to think yeah
yeah so that's that's a look before the
present now are we all gonna get hot and
bothered about this one of the constant
sources of amusement to me is when
people in the media at to outrage at
Trump being Trump he's from get over it
he's been from for a long time I
remember I had this bit a bit of a tiff
online with Bill Kristol formerly the
Weekly Standard now over at the bulwark
under the template with Bill Kristol
over this sort of thing Trump did
something that was very Trumpy and
pretty funny on his Twitter account and
bill kristol was like this disgraces the
office of the presidency and I tweeted
back to my bill lighten up I really are
we going to act with fresh outrage
every time Trump does what Trump does of
all the things to be outraged about oh
really gonna be outraged because he
insulted Nancy Pelosi's dentures come on
come on that doesn't even rank in his
list of top 100 insults that's not even
close to his most insulting or vulgar
statement probably of the day absurd but
here at CNN being very very upset about
all this and then a house
publican defended from tweet saying that
you know he's upset about things
yeah he's upset about things he's being
impeached on the basis of thin evidence
I'd be upset about that too does that
mean that I would be tweeting from the
Oval Office
where we're great presidents where
Ronald Reagan once at being a teeth man
look at that lookit she needs a little
bit more a little bit more Pepsodent
look at that oh my gosh look at those
days that he no but also the look of
high dudgeon from the people that CNN is
is getting rather tiresome I think most
Americans are kind of bored of it
frankly the president has a very
unorthodox style of messaging it's not
the way that I talk or that I would I
would tweet but look the president's
very frustrated about how he's been
treated he lashes out sometimes and I
think a lot of the American people
understand that it was it was mentioned
just a moment ago and your discussion
that he really hadn't gotten due process
he didn't get a fair trial in the house
and that's very bothersome to him
because it's there's gonna be an
asterisk by his presidency in the in the
history books that he was the third
president to be impeached by the house
and it's really not fair the way it's
been done so he's frustrated about that
so an N CNN's I how how could he say
this this is featured all over the media
House Republicans says he's frustrated
no no but let's be real about this
everybody who believes there is
insufficient evidence thinks this whole
process is a sham Lindsey Graham 2.0
among them
senator Graham says I I'm not gonna
pretend that I'm that I'm an unbiased
source on this I have nothing but to
stain for this entire idiotic process I
have nothing but disdain for this I'm
trying to make myself clear what you're
doing in the house is bad for the
presidency you're impeaching the
President of the United States in a
matter of weeks not months yet a
two-year investigation that wasn't
enough I think this whole thing is a
crock you're showing the president out
the process in the house any partisan
group could do this in the future
you're weaponizing impeachment and I
want to end it I don't want to
legitimize it I hate what they're doing
well in a second I want to get to the
Democrats attempting to make it seem
bipartisan and a pretty good giveaway
that Democrats were in purple districts
in Trump districts who won in the last
election cycle are very nervous about
this impeachment process a pretty solid
piece of evidence on that coming up in
one second first it is that time of
the season you're gonna be sending a lot
of gift packages I know that I am and
that means that normally I'd have to
schlep all of those packages over to the
post office
well that means loading my kids up into
the car slepping all that over the post
office I only have two hands one for
each child so that means I would have to
use my teeth to carry these packages
into the post office I'm not gonna do
that instead I'm gonna be using
stamps.com why because I can get all the
fantastic services of the US Postal
Service directly to my computer whether
you're a small office sending invoices
and online sellers shipping out products
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps comm can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official US postage 24/7 for
any letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it's your mail
carrier or drop it in the mailbox it is
indeed that simple with stamps comm you
get five cents off every first-class
stamp and up to 40% off Priority Mail
well over 700 thousand small businesses
already use stamps calm life is too
short to be schlepping all of your stuff
over to the post office and then waiting
in line don't spend a minute of your
holiday season at the post office this
year instead sign up for stamps comm
there is no risk and with my promo code
Shapiro you get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale great deal no
long term commitments or contracts using
our code you'll be saving money and
supporting the show just head on over to
stamps com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in Shapiro
that is stamps comm enter Shapiro stamps
comm never go to the post office again
okay we're gonna get to more on
impeachment and a pretty good piece of
evidence that Democrats who actually are
not in blue districts are pretty worried
about how this thing is going to go but
first great news game we have a perfect
gift for you to give this holiday season
it's the gift of me no I'm not gonna let
go to somebody's house or anything but
you can give somebody a daily wire
membership from now until January 1st
all insider plus gift memberships will
be 25% off that is 1/4 off in case you
didn't do your fractions that means your
loved one will get all the fantastic
perks plus the majestic leftist yours
tumbler and you will receive the savings
so you're saving money and you're giving
somebody great gift if you're not
already a subscriber you're really
missing out head on over to daily we're
calm and subscribe again and it's 25%
off all insider plus gift memberships
this holiday season give them a gift
they will thank you for all year long
head on over to daily wire comm slash
gift and get your 25% off again that is
daily wire calm
gift to get 25% off don't wait stop
depriving yourself come join the fun
this is the largest fastest corn
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
the Democrats are now attempting to
pretend that this thing is a little bit
bipartisan so they're the reason they're
doing this is they're gonna try
apparently freshmen Democrats are trying
to push for Justin a mash as the
impeachment manager in the House Amash
has been a rogue Congress person who's
elected as a Republican now he's
registered as an independent
he's a very small government guy sort of
a Ron Paul libertarian in a lot of ways
a group of thirty freshmen Democrats led
by representative Dean Phillips of
Minnesota has asked House leaders to
consider the libertarian who left the
Republican Party earlier this year for
the small group tasked with arguing its
case for removing Trump in the upper
chamber according to several Democratic
officials the thinking is the Washington
Post reporting according to these people
is that Amash would reach conservative
voters in a way Democrats can
potentially bolstering their case to the
public which of course is untrue given
the fact that I mash had to leave the
Republican Party and may in fact lose
his seat he would also provide Democrats
cover from GOP accusations that are
pursuing a partisan impeachment Amash is
one of the most conservative members of
the House and a vocal Trump critic
Phillip said to the extent that this can
be bipartisan it should I think
including representative Amash amongst
the impeachment managers is a smart move
for both the country for the substance
and for the optics
I love the newfound respect that Amash
is receiving this is what we in the in
the conservative movement called the
strange new respect every so often if
you criticize the right if something on
the right goes wrong and you point it
out you get strange new respect well
justin amash has been receiving that
ever since he decided that he'd come out
in favor of impeachment is he actually
gonna be given that no the Democratic
leadership does not trust Amash with
that because they never know what he
might say Amash is enough of a rogue
that he might start going off on the
Democrats spending habits and invasions
of government meanwhile representative
Jeff van drew who's an anti impeachment
Democrat is now going to switch parties
this demonstrates again that these
Democrats are not quite as popular on
this thing among independents as they
say they are according to the New York
Times representative Jeff Andra of New
Jersey a moderate Democrat was among the
party staunchest opponents of impeaching
Trump told aides on Saturday he plans to
switch parties and declare himself a
Republican as soon as next week just as
the house is casting its historic votes
on articles of impeachment and White
House meeting on Friday the Andrew sawed
Trump's blessing for the move
which could be critical to his ability
to avoid a primary challenge next year
the president urged him to make the jump
according to two Democrats and one
Republican who spoke on the condition of
anonymity because of the talks were
intended to be private andrew has spoken
with senior advisors to trump about
announcing his switch at an event at the
White House either immediately before or
just after the house votes on two
articles of impeachment which is
expected to happen on Wednesday
according to Republicans and Democrats
now typically when a member of a of a
big political party has switched that's
been big news
go away back to Jim Jeffords switching
parties and the switching control of the
Senate of the United States back in the
early 2000s but this is obviously big
news in the middle of an impeachment
hearing you have a guy who is a blue
vote in a in a red district in New
Jersey switching parties because he
believes that he's not gonna be able to
win re-election if he supports the
impeachment the move would provide a
silver lining for Trump as he becomes
the third president ever to be impeached
according to the New York Times the
decision by Van who reflects the heavy
political consequences hanging over next
week's impeachment vote particularly for
moderate Democrats and districts that
supported Trump in 2016 they're out 30
Democrats who are sitting in districts
that supported Trump Republicans are
targeting those districts heavily the
impeachment vote could come back to
haunt all of those people Jerry Nadler
for his part leading me house shoe
dicier committee ripped into Van drew
saying that the real reason he's not
doing this the real reason he's
switching is not out of principle it's
out of political fear he's reacting to
is a public polling that shows he can't
get renominated the his electorate in in
his district is 24% too renowned 8 him
the 60% and nominate somebody else the
more to the point this is not political
we should not be looking at those things
this is the defense of our democracy do
we stay a democratic republic or do we
turn into a Terran II what is
fascinating here is that members of Van
Drewes own constituency Michel Suleiman
the Atlantic County Democratic Chairman
has she wrote a letter to ban Druze and
I'm imploring you to vote in favor of
impeachment a no vote on impeachment
will suppress Democratic turnout down
ballot which my organization cannot
sustain in other words if they try this
impeachment and it turns out to come to
nothing that could actually suppress the
Democratic efforts to get out the vote
everybody's so depressed and it is
interesting the Democrats are this early
playing the card that they almost
expected Trump to win if he's not
impeached
that's the only reason that you put out
there the preventative message that if
Trump is elected it's a legitimate
because you actually expect that he's
going to win meanwhile in the Senate
Chuck Schumer is attempting to militate
but he has no power in the Senate so it
doesn't really matter just as this house
thing has been run as a sham the Senate
thing will be run as a sham also the
Senate Republicans are going to rush
this thing through Mitch McConnell
Senate majority leader he has no
interest in dragging this thing out and
he does not think that the Democrats
proved their case in the house so Chuck
Schumer is now trying to force Mitch
McConnell to call a bunch of witnesses
from the White House
those witnesses from the White House
already said they're not testifying in
front of Congress and the Democrats
could have called them in the house all
they had to do is wait this thing out
but they refused to wait this thing out
because they know they're not gonna get
it so instead Schumer is going to
pretend that McConnell was engaging in a
cover-up by not calling the same
witnesses Democrats refused to wait for
over on the house side according to
Axios com Schumer has now sent a letter
to McConnell in which he asks the
Republican leaders to call for witnesses
who refused to testify before the house
impeachment committees the witnesses
Schumer has asked for I'll have direct
knowledge of trump administration
decisions he wants the Senate to call
Mick Mulvaney the acting White House
chief of staff john bolton the former
NSA Michael Duffy the Associate Director
for national security Office of
Management and Budget and Robert Blair
senior advisor to Mulvaney the Senate
Democratic leaders request may appeal to
some moderate Republicans but that
obviously is going nowhere and the
reason that it is going nowhere
obviously is because why exactly would
McConnell call people that again the
Democrats could have called but would
not wait for let's not pretend here the
Democrats had no authority to call these
people some of them they didn't even
issue legal subpoenas to some of them
they were just like here's a request to
show up at the house and these people
like no don't think so he's like
obstruction of Congress that's the way
this thing has gone so far so it's a
sham the house will vote to impeach i
mid-january this thing will be over at
the Senate you know I'll be in the past
and people have already taken their
stances but there are some varying poll
statistics on how popular this is
there's a Fox News poll that said 54% of
Americans support the impeachment at
this point but there are other polls
suggesting that it's well under 50% the
Fox News poll is actually a little bit
of an outlier suffice it to say that
after it fails in the Senate
I I do not think that it does any damage
to president Trump long term it didn't
do any damage to Bill Clinton long term
obviously he was impeached in the house
and then acquitted in the Senate
meanwhile the fight over the FBI and the
Intelligence Committee continues over
the weekend James Comey found himself on
the hot seat the former head of the FBI
who had declared himself the wisest and
fairest person the kind of guy who in
his off hours just goes out into nature
and stares at trees and takes upward
angled pictures of himself hero shots
backlit that guy who's appearing on
national TV with Chris Wallace and he
acknowledged yeah you know that whole
FISA process that I oversaw going after
Carter page maybe I was like a little
overconfidence on that whole thing also
he's wearing the world's ugliest jacket
I know it's beside the point I just felt
like I needed to point it out here's
James Comey he's right I was wrong I was
overconfident in the procedures that the
FBI and justice had built over 20 years
I thought they were a bust enough it's
incredibly hard to get a FISA I was
overconfident in those because he's
right there was real sloppiness 17
things the user should have been in the
applications or at least discussed and
characterized differently it was not
acceptable and so he's right I was wrong
you make it sound like you're a
bystander and I witness you were the
director of the FBI well a lot of this
was going on sir sure I'm responsible
for that's what I'm telling you I was
wrong I was overconfident as director
he's become just wow remember when that
guy was the image of the Wallman showed
up like Gary Cooper in High Noon I'm
here to do some frontier justice and
that's well I I guess there were
mistakes made and Kris was like well
yeah you were in charge of the agency
right I was I was overconfident the
overconfidence wasn't the problem
maybe maybe is that there was a system
of bias in which the people who were
investigating this thing thought that
they were gonna come down on one side or
the other and by the way if you noticed
the treatment of the Hillary Clinton
case next to the treatment of the Donald
Trump case what you see is that top
members of the FBI were firmly convinced
that Hillary had done nothing wrong
James Comey rewrote the law in order to
make it that Hillary Clinton had done
nothing wrong
meanwhile his FBI was pursuing a FISA
warrant against Kyra Paige that
according to the IG
rife with 17 errors on four separate
applications or people working on this
thing over and over
error after error after error the the
continued involvement of the crap steal
dossier in the entire investigation
chris wallace asks the relevant question
he says why is it that every single
mistake was made in the same direction
how exactly are you claiming there was
no bias here parts to this report the
Horowitz says there was no political
bias and opening the investigation he
talks about problems with the five big
problems with the FISA process but isn't
it harder to argue that there was no
political bias overall when you see 17
mistakes made by three teams on four
separate FISA applications hey this is
exactly right
this is exactly right now the the if you
read the actual IG report the claim is
that he has to overcome a very low
standard in order to find that there was
no bias all he has to do is overcome the
presumption that there was bias meaning
oh he has to do is say okay they gave a
plausible excuse that that bias is not
the explanation I'll just accept that
but the fact is that if you looked at
this many errors it's like the argument
about bias in the media people on the
right they look at social medias Twitter
how Twitter runs its business how Google
runs its business they say okay why is
that every single error committed by
these businesses cuts against the right
they look at the media they look at the
New York Times in the Washington Post
when was the last time that the New York
Times of The Washington Post had to
correct his story because it was too
biased in favor of the right or against
somebody on the left and the answer is
pretty much never and so he say right
when all the errors line up in one
direction this is no longer just people
making mistakes this is people making
mistakes in a particular direction and
that's exactly what happened over at the
FBI meanwhile Adam Schiff it turns out
was lying pretty much openly to the
American people there are these dueling
memos that went out we reviewed them at
the time one from Devin Nunes and one
from Adam Schiff about the nature of the
FISA warrants Devin Nunes had suggested
that the FISA warrant was completely
botched that it was based on the steel
dossier that the judge had not been
properly informed of the bias inside the
steel dossier and Shifa said no no no
the FISA warrant was perfectly fine here
as Chris Wallace pointing out to Adam
Schiff a dude you seemed to have lied to
the American people at that time in 2018
you said the
bi and Department of Justice did not
quote omit material information
apparently you did not know at the time
that in fact Steele's main Russian
sources had told the FBI that he had
misrepresented what that Russian source
had said and that the FBI knew at the
time the quarter page in fact was acting
as a contact as a unofficial source for
the CIA given what you know now we
talked earlier to director Comey and he
basically said I was wrong in what I've
represented back in 2018 are you willing
to admit that you were wrong in your
defense of the FBI's FISA process I'm
certainly willing to admit that the
Inspector General found serious abuses
of FISA that I was unaware of oh that he
was unaware of he was unaware of them he
kept claiming over and over and over
that he had insider information that
Trump was going to be unmasked as a
Russian cats ball and I was like oh well
I just didn't have the information oh is
that what it is or is that your a
congenital liar and that you spend a lot
of your time lying Adam chef who led the
impeachment process against Trump it is
impossible to separate out all these
strands and for the American people I
think it's very difficult to separate
out all these strands you got Comey and
the FBI committing a series of at best
errors that harmed the president leading
to a two-year investigation that ends up
finding nothing in the way of actual
Trump Russia collusion and then that's
followed by a Ukraine process that's led
by Adam Schiff the same guy who was
leading up the the Trump Muller
investigation in the house and
apparently lying repeatedly to the
American public all its gonna come out
from this is that the American people
don't have time to watch all this they
don't they don't have time to separate
out all the strands and the reason they
don't have time to separate out all the
strands is because everyone here is a
politically motivated actor there is not
even a shred of honesty apparently on
any side and so most Americans are gonna
go either I like Trump or I don't like
Trump either the economy's good or the
economy isn't and that's how mana vote
that's how this thing comes down in the
end and that's why you're starting to
see the Democrats panic and it really is
panic there are two separate articles in
the New York Times today trying to talk
down the economy when I say talk down
the economy I don't mean like they're
saying that the economy is going to
downturn everybody always says that I
remember saying it during the Obama
years
oh sure you know the economy's not as
strong as Trump says as Obama says it is
there to supper
articles in the New York Times today
talking about why GDP numbers are false
and also why Trump is not succeeding in
the swing states okay there's only one
problem he is succeeding in the swing
states and the economy is incredibly
incredibly strong right now so there is
a there's an article in The New York
Times by Ben Castleman and Carl Russell
it says there are economic warning signs
for Trump in the Midwest and then it
shows a graphic and the graphic shows
percentage change in total employment
every single state in the United States
has seen an increase in change in total
employment between December 2016 and
October 2019 since Trump took office
every single state by the way the states
that are doing the best unsurprisingly
happen to be the states that are the
least regulated and have the highest
access to human capital states in the
south tend to be doing particularly well
Nevada has seen a nine point one percent
increase in employment Texas has seen a
six point six percent increase in
employment Colorado has seen a six point
four percent increase in employment Utah
nine point six percent revenue these are
big big numbers Florida six point nine
percent what are the areas they're not
been growing as fast naturally the areas
that you would expect right the areas of
manufacturing areas that have been down
turning for a while so because of
technological increases but still
Minnesota is up 2.2 percent Wisconsin's
up 1.6 percent Michigan is up 1.8
percent Ohio is up 1.6 percent
Pennsylvania is up 2.6 percent it's
interesting to note that there are some
lefty states liberal states that have
really been lagging as well Ohio's up
1.6 percent as well according to the New
York Times though job growth has been
slow in key states yes but it's called
job growth job growth apart from
agriculture and manufacturing everything
is going ok said Ernie Gross and
economists at Creighton University in
Omaha who publishes an economic index
that tracks nine states for Minnesota
Arkansas in this part of the country
that's not comforting those are two
industries we depend on yes but those
industries we're never going to be held
up absent massive subsidies from the
federal government but I love that the
the New York Times is trying to claim
that this is a problem for Trump again
economic growth across the board is not
a problem for Trump it is a very good
thing for president from there's not
another article of New York Times today
from David Leonhardt well why you
shouldn't believe these GDP numbers
you seem to believe them when Barack
Obama was president now all the sudden
you don't believe the GDP numbers
instead it's that Americans are just fat
dissatisfied they're dissatisfied
because GDP keeps on rising but it no
longer tracks the well-being of most
Americans well actually it does track
the well-being of most Americans in
terms of the products and services
available to them in terms of living
standards in the United States it does
track that fairly well the GDP
undervalues the growth of the American
economy because the GDP has always been
about what is spent on products and
services so services that are free like
for example every time you use Google
Maps you just added value to your life
that did not add to the GDP in any way
but so many of the things that we take
advantage of on a daily basis aren't
things that don't add to GDP America's
growth has been far more explosive than
GDP numbers have shown over the past few
decades because information technology
is particularly hard to value inside GDP
but according to David Leonhardt its GDP
is overestimating the amounts of growth
happening in the economy and that's why
you should vote Trump the desperation
here you can feel it it's getting strong
okay time for some things I like and
then things I hate so would you like to
watch an incredibly stupid movie that is
also fun so I'm into incredibly stupid
movies that are fun my wife particularly
likes them I have once upon a time in
Hollywood on on rental but I know that I
can't watch that with my wife she's not
a Tarantino person I'm not either but at
least I can take the blood and gore what
she is into is dumb action movies which
is one of the reasons I love my wife dr.
Shapiro is very into dumb action movies
and this is a completely stupid action
movie that has some great action
sequences and is also very dumb as I say
Hobbs and Shaw so first of all let's
just say this Dwayne the rock Johnson is
a national treasure and everything that
he is in is wonderful and I don't care
how stupid it is rampage is wonderful no
matter how dumb it is I will go and I
will watch Jumanji too I will do it
don't make me don't make me turn this
bus around it will happen this movie is
a spin-off of The Fast and Furious
franchise and it features Jason Statham
another one of my personal favorites
have you never seen him in the
transporter he's great he's great in the
Italian chop also they make that kind of
cute reference to it in this movie Hobbs
and shot it's at least half an hour too
long but it is dramatically stupid and
wonderful at the same time here is a
little bit of the preview for Hobbs and
Shaw
now in serious trouble understatement
let's get old-school
his movies
so ridiculous and yet it is it is fun
Idris Elba plays the villain I'm a bigot
or salvor fan I have said that Idris
Elba would make a good James Bond which
which he would but this movie I can't
say it enough dumb action movies are
America and if you love America and this
is the kind of movie that you're
probably into so check it out Hobbs and
raw vailable on rental for like $4.99 on
Amazon so that was definitely a good
deal if you got a big screen at home
totally worth it okay okay time for a
quick thing that I hate so the the House
Democrats and President Trump have been
assuring in an era of goodwill believe
it or not when it comes to passing
legislation so over the weekend the
House Democrats have passed a National
Defense Authorization Act budget by a
377 to 48 vote basically everybody wants
to clear the tables for 2020 we will be
spending 738 billion dollars on a
defense bill it has some good stuff it
funds the us-mexico border wall the
space force and continued us support for
the saudi-led war in Yemen it hands
Trump a big win according to Business
Insider as Democrats are simultaneously
on the brink of impeaching him it also
does raise spending we have we're
blowing out spending at insane insane
rates also the Democrats are working on
passing the u.s. MCA which is the
replacement for NAFTA which does have
some enormous giveaways to the unions it
basically restricts the amounts of a car
that has to be manufacture in the United
States in order to avoid tariffs it
restricts the the wages that can be paid
in other countries in order to avoid
tariffs so that's good for American car
manufacturing it is not good at all for
the for the American consumer it's good
for unions but again as we saw in the
1940s 50s and 60s in the United States
car industry what is good for American
unions when it comes to the car industry
is not particularly good for the car
industry in the long run because
eventually those tariffs come down and
everybody else is more competitive Pat
Toomey is very critical of the new NAFTA
deal here he is explaining we've had
trade deficits with the rest of the
world for over 40 consecutive years and
what country has the biggest economy
the highest standard of living the
strongest growth and the best prospects
going forward we do and that's because
trade deficits don't matter that money
gets reinvested back in the United
States
so unfortunately us MCA is an exercise
through all kinds of new provisions to
diminish trade and that's why I hope
Republicans will reconsider this we've
historically recognized that we're all
better off with more open markets why do
you think the administration thought
policy had more leverage than anything I
don't have an explanation for that Chuck
but in the end there's no question it's
a complete capitulation to Pelosi now
there's a lot of talk about how this is
going to help auto companies in the
United States may help domestically
based auto companies but a lot of auto
companies that are based in foreign
nations have built factories in the
United States
the increase in labor cost in places
like Mexico and the United States means
that maybe those cars get built too
overseas instead and then shipped into
the United States if they're not going
to be able to meet those requirements of
being manufactured in the United States
anyway according to The Wall Street
Journal what is actually in the u.s. MCA
is US labor unions and Democrats have
tried to unionize Mexican workers to
drive up wages in the Mexican auto
industry which of course means that cars
are gonna cost more for American
consumers all fun and games for many of
the members of the unions like the UAW
not necessarily fun and games for the
American consumer who eventually is
going to opt for the cheaper car anyway
because that is what has historically
happened the u.s. MCA according to The
Wall Street Journal also significantly
tightens the rules that the auto
industry has to follow in order to trade
vehicles duty-free in the United States
in North America a certain proportion of
a car will have to be produced by
workers with higher wages a greater
proportion of components will have to
originate in North America again that
hurts consumers a deal to pass us MCA
means farmers of major crops don't have
to worry about President Trump
potentially pulling out of the existing
NAFTA it leaves them fewer major export
and leaving them fewer at major export
markets this is the good side of the end
the US MC a big drug makers are likely
to be disappointed because the Democrats
did push the Trump administration to
remove language that would have
protected expensive biologic drugs from
generic imitators for ten years the
existing NAFTA treaty has no such drug
protections so there are some upsides
and some downsides here bottom line is
we are blowing out spending Nancy Pelosi
got a lot of wins for the union's inside
the new NAFTA and a lot of this is
happening
in the run-up to the election
specifically because Trump wants the
tables cleared this is also why he
signed a partial trade deal with the
Chinese in order to clear the decks for
2020 again politically smart good for
the United States long run probably not
there should be bipartisan understanding
that China is in fact a geopolitical
enemy of the United States but absent
that understanding Trump signing this
thing it makes political sense he
doesn't want the Chinese sinking the
economy a month before the election
meanwhile Democrats are working on even
more legislation according to the
Washington Examiner the house will vote
on legislation to fund the government
for the fiscal year which will dodge a
government shutdown and lawmakers will
also likely vote on a long-awaited major
trade deal between the u.s. Mexico and
Canada this week Pelosi a California
Democrat has won passage of several
major bills in December including
prescription drug legislation a defense
spending authorization measure and a
bill that overhauls the immigrant guest
worker program in a clear signal that
Pelosi wants to shift the focus away
from impeachment she designated
representative Kim fryer at Washington
Democrat who represents a swing district
to deliver the party's swing address a
weekly address rather Schreyer
downplayed the impeachment vote she said
in my district it's not impeachment is
not what is on the front page of the
newspapers in Washington DC it's what
are you gonna do to bring down the cost
of prescription drugs Republicans who
oppose the impeachment have repeatedly
criticized House Democrats for focusing
on impeachment Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell announced the trade deal
the u.s. Mexico Canada trade agreement
he said it would not get a full vote
until after the Senate takes up a trial
to consider the articles of impeachment
so Democrats are trying to force this
room again demonstrating they don't
actually have a lot of faith in the
impeachment effort they believe that in
the end this is going to harm them which
is why they're trying to ram through a
bunch of legislation Trump also wants a
bunch of legislation rammed through so
he can add to his list of
accomplishments even if those
accomplishments are not particularly
conservative and I am starting to hear
kickback from certain conservative
members of the Senate and the and the
House of Representatives saying that
these deals that he's cutting with
Pelosi have been like every other deal
he's cut with Pelosi rife with enormous
amounts of government spending and
giveaways to Nancy Pelosi zki
constituencies getting things done at
the federal level was never the goal of
the founding fathers but since we now
live in a world where it's considered a
complete catastrophe if any sort of
gridlock takes place of course Trump is
going to do this in the lead-up to 2020
that's not a justification for signing
bad bills it is X in X plane
what exactly Trump is doing so
impeachment means nothing it's not going
to accomplish anything the only thing in
the end that is going to continue to
result is America blowing out the
spending and that's on Republicans and
it's on Democrats okay we will be here a
little bit later for two additional
hours of contents otherwise we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pavel white house key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by micro Amina hair and makeup is by
Jess WA all Vera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]